Borno State in Northeastern Nigeria has
seen 14 years of Boko Haram violence but
it's slowly emerging from the crisis
with improved security hundreds of
millions of dollars are being spent on
new buildings and Roads and
rehabilitating lives and livelihoods
what we did was to ensure that we
created the enabling environment for the
population to earn their means of
livelihood by themselves
we started returning back people to the
lgf in order to address the root causes
of the Insurgency which are not limited
to including poverty including climate
vulnerabilities and increasing
infrastructure
thanks to the biggest military spending
in Nigeria areas overrun by Boko Haram
Fighters have been taken back
the significant drop in attacks by Boko
Haram and isil Affiliates is boosting
Commerce in the Northeast here at the
main Market in my degree Traders from
Chad Cameroon and Niger are loading up
merchandise to take across the border
and that is creating more jobs and
incomes what the north is gained in
terms of Peace are the areas of the
north have lost
the truth has to be accepted there are
still people there are still Villages
that are under the control or Bandits
there are a lot of idps that are not in
that area
further south agitations for
Independence has led to the killing of
hundreds of people in attacks on
civilians security forces and government
buildings police say there are at least
88 armed groups across Nigeria from
Bandits to Fighters and militias
supported by state officials this armed
non-state group are the number one
security element or threat to the 2023
elections these groups the ads have the
capacity to not only disrupt the
upcoming presidential election but
launch Nigeria into deeper crisis
armed groups here have killed tens of
thousands of people in the last 15 years
Nigerian vote is considered security as
their biggest concern and would want
whoever wins Saturday's election to
tackle it head-on
but with armed groups and some
politicians accused of using violence as
means toward their objectives even the
election voters want to use the effect
change now appears under threat Ahmad
agrees Al Jazeera maiduguri